la ftq revendique maintenant de fixer le
salaire minimum à 18 $ l'heure au québec
dès 2022 le salaire minimum actuel au
québec et 2,13 dollars 50 daniel boyer
président de la ftq karl blackburn pdg
du conseil du patronat sont avec nous tu
boyer vous veniez la bataille pour 15
dollars pourquoi maintenant 18 dollars
écoutez on a lancé la campagne du
salaire minimum à 15 dollars le 1er mai
de size ça fait déjà mais presque six
ans puis moi je l'aï dit publiquement et
je lui dis également omis de ce boulet
lock on tiendrait pas la route
on le dit déjà depuis 2018 qu'il fallait
en 2018 porter le salaire minimum à 15
dollars parce que l'ontario la colombie
britannique l'alberta ont eues on va
augmenter de façon substantielle leurs
salaires minimums donc qu'il fallait
aller de l'avant mais comment on s'est
fié pour le 18 $ l'heure oui c'est bien
ça la mesure du fait de faibles revenus
la communauté européenne statistique
canada même au québec on appelait ça le
seuil de pauvreté à 20 66 60 % du
salaire médian et la boxe alors on vit
dans la pauvreté donc 60% du salaire
médian ses hôtes du revenu médian c'est
un peu plus que 18 $ l'heure on a on
aura 18 qui on veut ce qu'on veut le but
ultime c'est que les travailleurs et
travailleuses qui travaille à plein mais
puisse se sortir de la pauvreté plus vie
dignement et décemment au québec en 2021
alors monsieur blackburn vous entendez
ça ce discours où les gens veulent bien
vivre justement est ce que vous êtes
d'accord à ce qu'on aille jusqu'à 18 $
pour le salaire minimum tout le monde
veut bien lui mais malheureusement
l'économie ne fonctionne pas tout à fait
de cette façon et en mai dernier vous
avez mentionné salaire minimum a été
monté à 13 et 50 lorsqu'on compare le
salaire minimum au québec à travers
toutes les provinces du canada on se
situait au quatrième rang mais lorsqu'on
vient ajouter les différents programmes
sociaux les différents programmes pour
soutenir les familles à faible revenu
les crédits d'impôt associations
lorsqu'on regarde à la fin de l'année le
revenu disponible pour c
l'âge et le québec se classe premier au
canada donc c'est pas vrai qu'on est les
plus pauvres de la fédération canadienne
au contraire on a différents programmes
qui sont en place et en même temps le
salaire moyen est le salaire minimum ont
toujours est en corrélation
historiquement au québec et le rhassoul
varie entre 45 et 50% du salaire minimum
versus le salaire moyen est avec
l'augmentation de mai dernier le salaire
moyen versus ce salaire minimum et à
cinq ans pour ça donc on reste un
équilibre je comprends mais l' équilibre
je veux bien l'équilibré statique mais
quand monsieur boyer dit que beaucoup de
gens qui vivent sous le seuil de la
pauvreté même avec le salaire minimum
est ce que c'est pas un devoir de
corriger ça il ya beaucoup de programmes
qui existent monsieur fillion comme je
viens de mentionner et les gens plus
faible revenu au québec se classe
maintenant au premier rang lorsqu'on
additionne toutes les mesures mises en
place mais en même temps il ya une
capacité payer également pour les
employeurs de certains commerces à
certaines entreprises certains secteurs
qui ont des marges bénéficiaires
beaucoup plus aéré beaucoup plus mince
non point la capacité d'augmenter les
salaires à des eaux aussi importants
comme le souhaite monsieur boyer et bien
évidemment c'est viendraient fragiliser
l'activité économique elle à valence et
donc si les pme ferme c'est des
entreprises qui sont plus capables de
payer leurs employés on avance à quoi
monsieur boyer quelqu'un serait donc
le bienfait d'augmenter autant salaire
minimum
bah écoutez première mal là où on a
augmenté de façon substantielle salah
évidemment pour le veto américain
on l'a vu on l'a vu quand on a augmenté
de façon substantielle en ontario en
colombie-britannique et en alberta
le salaire minimum il ya pas eu de
fermeture il n'y a pas eu de pertes
d'emplois les époux bataille nous on y
croit plus ou moins maintenant je veux
juste là demain sur les mesures fiscales
c'est pas moi qui dois dire que les
besoins fiscal ne doivent pas être bien
au contraire sauf que parce que le
financement direct des entreprises qui
payent pas suffisamment les travailleurs
des majeurs fiscales aussi ben moi et
l'ensemble des citoyens et des
citoyennes qui les payent hockey c'est
bien connaître mais à notre sens ça
devrait être les employeurs qui paye
décemment des employés et s il faut
aimer de plus petites entreprises à un
payer ce salaire minimum là mais on
devrait le faire et moi j'ai hâte qu'on
inverse la logique au lieu de se poser
la question quel est l'impact va avoir
l'alimentation du salaire minimum moi
j'aimerais ça qu'on se dise au salaire
actuel escale des travailleurs et
travailleuses sont capables de bing maps
décemment non mais on devrait corriger
monsieur blackburn au dessus si on n'est
pas capable d'avoir une activité
économique qui est forte qu'il ya sur
une gouvernance économique et qui est
capable de prospérer à l'intérieur du
québec malheureusement seront pas
capables de se payer l'ensemble des
services publics que la société voudrait
bien avoir bien évidemment tout le monde
va avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
il ya une réalité économique dans lequel
nous évoluons et cette réalité et les
fragiles on le voit bien la dernière
année était extrêmement difficile pour
les employeurs au canada mais au québec
particulièrement il ya eu des mesures
qui ont été mises en place une chance
que ces mesures ont été mises en place
pour soutenir une certaine activité
économique mais on le voit bien c'est
quand même très fragile et la relance
économique on est à près de vouloir
vivre au québec elle est la même partout
à travers la planète et nos compétiteurs
ne sont plus nos compétiteurs du village
voisin ou de la province voisine c'est
maintenant quand le coach n'a voisins je
mentionne que le salaire minimum
dépasser 15 $ présentement en alberta en
colombie-britannique au nunavut on est à
16 dollars de l'heure je remercie à vous
deux monsieur bourgogne se voyait merci
bien merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh